une première réussie pour le Paris
Legends Championship à 5 an en niine la
compétition organisée de ce vendredi 9 à
ce dimanche 11 septembre sur les Green
de l'Albatros au Golf National a réuni
plus d'une cinquantaine de golfeurs de
légende c'est une première édition pour
la France il s'agit du Tour européen
senior c'est-à-dire les joueurs qui ont
plus de 50 ans les légendes qui ont
donné 30 ans de leur vie à notre sport
les gens avec lesquels on a grandi qu'on
a vu sur le parcours depuis des années
parmi les golfeurs le fantasque
américain John dy l'Anglais David
Russell ou encore le français de 50 ans
Jean vandevel de 4 fois vainqueur sur le
circuit professionnel ça équiv à l'OP de
France senior donc oui effectivement
c'est c'est une pour moi c'est une étape
importante du calendrier un plateau
d'exception qui a attiré plus d'un
millier de passionnés sur les 3 jours de
compétition d'abord c'est un moment
privilégé pour nous les amateurs de golf
au cheveux blancs de pouvoir côtoyer
idoles de près c'est un moment sympa de
pouvoir les approcher on est vraiment à
proximité des joueurs donc c'est sympa
il fait beau c'est gratuit en plus donc
il faut vraiment profiter quoi hauteur
d'une carte de 69 Magnus P atlevi
remporte la compétition avec un bilan de
Mo- 8 sur l'Albatros le Suédois signe au
passage sa première victoire sur le
senior Tour européen rendez-vous l'année
prochaine pour la 2e édition du Paris
Legends
Championship